bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux on commence avec la découverte
possible de faux cils martien publié
dans la très sérieuse revue nature
communications
le rover spirit avait photographié il y
a dix ans et étrange structure
géologique martienne fait de silice au
palliser uniques en leur genre leur
origine restaient inexpliqués jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
des géologues viennent en effet de
découvrir dans des geysers du chili des
structures en silice au palliser
similaire qui s'agglomèrent grâce à des
tapis bactérien ainsi la présence de
telles structures sur mars attesterait
de l'existence d'une vie passée sur la
planète rouge
des fossiles martien le plus intéressant
et qu'il ne s'agit pas de la première
fois qu'on signale des fossiles de tapis
bactérien sur mars
je vous renvoie à une autre de nos
vidéos plus complète à ce sujet on reste
dans le brouillard du doute
avec l' annonce que vous avez
certainement vu passer de la découverte
d'un cerveau fossile de dinosaure
néanmoins ceci n'est pas du tout un
cerveau fossile mais en réalité un
fragment de boîte crânienne à
l'intérieur duquel les rayons x ont mis
en évidence la possible préservation de
quelques fibres ayant potentiellement
fait partie d'un cerveau de dinosaures
attention donc aux effets d'annoncé mais
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'il pourrait
s'agir de tissu cérébral préservés et
que ça c'est déjà pas si mal
toujours du côté des dinosaures
découverts il ya plusieurs décennies
déjà mais décrit seulement maintenant
après des dizaines d'années de travail
voici savane aux eaux russes
diamantinasaurus et austro poséidon tous
les trois découvert dans le crétacé
d'australie pour les deux premiers et du
brésil pour le dernier ils représentent
les plus gros dinosaures découverts
jusqu'à l'or dans leurs pays respectifs
mésozoïque encore avec la découverte de
la plus vieille fleurs connu une puce
panis qui vient du jurassique de chine
parfaitement préservée elle date de 162
millions d'années et a été trouvé dans
le liaoning sa découverte
plus de 37 millions d'années l'âge des
premières plantes à fleurs les
angiospermes on passe à la
paléogénétique avec l' annonce durant le
7ème symposium international
d'archéologie biomoléculaire du
séquençage du génome d'à propos s'il ya
un vieux de 200 mille ans paléo l'oxo
dont antique us une espèce et anne keane
un mammouth ni un éléphant ni un de
leurs ancêtres cette analyse encore
préliminaire pourrait bien réécrire
complètement l'histoire évolutive des
éléphants les auteurs ont en effet
déclaré avoir découvert plusieurs traces
d'hybridation entre espèces éteintes de
proboscidiens paléo molécules toujours
le journal y life a publié la découverte
de protéines préserver dans des
coquilles d'oeuf d'autruche viennent de
3,8 millions d'années et provenant du
célèbre site paléontologique de light au
lit en tanzanie
rien de remarquable à première vue
puisque on avait déjà réussi à extraire
des protéines d'os de dinosaures bien
plus ancien mais cette découverte fait
naître l'espoir qu'un jour on puisse
retrouver des protéines ayant appartenu
à nos cousins les australopithèques dont
on retrouve les restes dans le même
gisement après le séquençage du génome
de l'homme de néandertal dans les années
2000 2010 ce serait certainement la plus
grande révolution en matière de paléo
génétique humaine de ce siècle
et puisqu'on en parle terminons enfin
avec néandertal la grotte du renne à
arcy sur cure en bourgogne est connu
pour avoir livré deux magnifiques dans
griffes et aux percées de trous laissant
supposer qu'il faisait partie de parures
en ces parures ainsi que les pierres
taillées chatel pérolienne sont datés de
44 à 40 mille ans ce qui est trop jeune
pour déterminer si elles ont été
fabriquées par néandertal où l'homme
moderne
les restes squelettiques humains
retrouvés associés auraient pu s'avérer
utile à cet égard mais ils sont trop
fragmentaires pour qu'on puisse les
reconnaître d'après leur anatomie
par contre ces derniers se sont avérées
suffisamment bien préservés pour qu'on y
retrouve des protéines les analyses
paléo moléculaire de ces ossements ont
ainsi pu démontrer que ces eaux étaient
ceux d'hommes de néandertal cette
découverte s'ajoute donc à celles des
structures en cercles de bruniquel des
peintures attribué à néandertal en
espagne ainsi qu'à d'autres parures fait
de griffes de rapaces vieille de cent
trente mille ans et qui tout suggère que
néandertal n'était pas une brute mai à
nîmes incapable de grandes prouesses
artistiques et d'une commission
semblable à la nôtre
la curiosité de cette émission c'est le
résultat inattendu d'une expérience
obtenu par une équipe de chimistes
nord-américaine en combinant
nanotechnologies et réaction
électrochimique
ils ont en effet réussi à transformer du
co2 en éthanol et ce avec un courant de
seulement 1,2 volts pour un rendement de
63 à 70 %
au delà de l'opportunité unique cela
offre de satisfaire l'insatiable soif de
certains épicurien
cette découverte ouvre la porte à
l'espoir de pouvoir un jour recycler le
dioxyde de carbone libérée dans
l'atmosphère par l'utilisation des
combustibles fossiles pour la rubrique
vintage nous remontons dans le temps
jusqu'en 1962 cette année fut déterrés
dans le nebraska aux états unis à
fossiles unique en son genre
les squelettes complets de deux
mammouths malemort les défenses
enchevêtrés les unes dans les autres
l'hypothèse la plus probable est qu'il
soit mort de soif ou d'épuisement après
s'être coincé dans cette position
inconfortable durant un combat ils
conservèrent cette position pendant
douze mille ans ce fossile d'un
comportement pétrifié est unique en son
genre et constitue le premier exemple
documenté de combat dans le registre
fossile
en effet la découverte du raptor se
battant avec le proto ceratops dans le
désert de gobi ne viendra que près de 10
ans plus tard il aura fallu quarante
longues années de préparation pour que
le fossile soit entièrement nettoyé et
il est désormais visible au musée de
l'université du nebraska les deux
mammouths patibulaire ont été surnommés
coop et march en référence deux
paléontologues qui s'était livré la
terrible guerre des os à l'époque de la
conquête de l'ouest
le coup de coeur de cette émission c'est
cet oiseau fossiles et au confuciusornis
vieux 230 millions d'années et
magnifiquement préservé provenant de
chine
il est même encore possibles par
endroits de voir ces différentes teintes
de plumes et les chercheurs viennent de
comprendre pourquoi c'est parce que des
fibres de kératine sont restés préserver
dans ses plumes et qu'elles ont formé
une sorte de protection pour des
molécules encore plus délicate des
traces de pigments contenant du cuivre
et du soufre avant cette découverte on
était parvenu à trouver des mélanosomes
qui n'était en fait que l'empreinte
fossilisés des organites contenant les
pigments c'était en se basant sur la
forme de ces mélanosomes que la couleur
de dino l'oiseau comme lancker nice
avait pu être reconstitué mais jamais on
avait découvert de restes de pigments
directement à l'intérieur de ces
organites ainsi cette découverte nous
fait entrer dans une nouvelle ère où il
sera peut-être possible de connaître la
véritable couleur du plumage des
dinosaures les 20 prochaines années qui
s'annonce risque d'être fort excitante
du point de vue paléontologique affaire
à suivre
c'était paléo news merci de l'avoir
suivi toutes les infos et les liens vers
les actus sont dans la description
abonnez vous pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens et à très bientôt